en el vídeo pasado utilizamos el teorema
del binomio para desarrollar además de a
la 4 y fue pues un poquito tedioso pero
ojalá que te haya gustado habría sido
mucho más útil si hubiéramos calculado
una potencia más grande como además ve a
la 8 pero lo que quiero hacer este video
es enseñarte que hay otra forma de hacer
esto y se trata de utilizar el triángulo
de pascal y si tenemos tiempo veremos
por qué estas dos ideas están tan
relacionadas entonces en lugar de a
desarrollar además ve a la 4 utilizando
esta fórmula del teorema del binomio voy
a calcularlo usando el triángulo de
pascal y algunos de los patrones que
vimos que seguían el desarrollo de un
binomio entonces déjame volver a
escribir lo que queremos desarrollar
déjame escribir por aquí el binomio que
queremos desarrollar
ve a la cuarta potencia y lo que voy a
hacer es construir el triángulo de
pascal y para eso empezamos con un 1 por
aquí y bueno este triángulo de pascal
básicamente lo que hace es que en cada
nivel vamos a estar contando la cantidad
de formas que hay de llegar a cada uno
de los nodos de ese nivel entonces
empezamos aquí con un 1 y pues hay dos
caminos que uno puede tomar y llegamos a
dos nuevos distintos en el primer nivel
este es el nivel cero y después pues no
nos interesa quedarnos nada más en el
nivel 1 o sea queremos llegar hasta el
nivel 4 entonces vamos a agregar otro
nivel y aquí pues tenemos una sola forma
de llegar a este nodo empezamos por aquí
nos vamos para acá y para acá
ok sin embargo para llegar a este nodo
tenemos dos formas distintas
empezamos por aquí nos vamos para acá y
luego para qué
empezamos por aquí nos vamos a este nodo
y llegamos de este lado a este nuevo
entonces hay dos formas de llegar a este
nuevo y finalmente hay una sola forma de
llegar a este último nodo entonces pues
agreguemos otro nivel a ver tenemos por
aquí
uno dos tres cuatro nuevos y para llegar
a este nodo hay una sola forma en que
seguir todo este camino entonces hay una
forma para llegar a este nodo pues
podemos seguir este camino para
conseguir este otro camino
esa es la segunda forma y podemos seguir
este último camino entonces hay tres
formas de llegar a este nodo y lo mismo
va a pasar por aquí o sea tenemos una
forma dos formas y tres formas y para
llegar a este nodo tenemos únicamente
una forma sin embargo todavía no
llegamos al nivel asociado con este
binomio a la cuarta potencia ok por que
este nivel está asociado con tomar un
binomio y elevarlo a la potencia cero
este nivel que es el nivel uno está
asociado con tomar un binomio y elevarlo
a la potencia 1 estos van a ser los
coeficientes este nivel a la potencia 2
este nivel a la potter
3 entonces tenemos que ver el siguiente
nivel para ver cuáles van a ser los
coeficientes de este binomio a la cuarta
potencia
cuántas formas hay de llegar a este
nuevo pues sólo podemos seguir este
camino entonces hay una sola forma
cuántas formas hay de llegar a este nodo
pues tenemos este camino también tenemos
este camino
este otro camino y esas son cuatro
formas distintas que hay para llegar a
este nodo vamos a hacer algo más
interesante que es decir ok hay tres
formas de llegar a este nuevo y hay
otras tres formas de llegar a este otro
nodo entonces tiene que haber tres más
tres seis formas de llegar a este nuevo
ok me imagino que con un poquito de
tiempo puedes deducir por qué para
encontrar la cantidad de formas de
llegar a este nuevo simplemente tenemos
que sumar la cantidad de formas de
llegar a estos dos nodos entonces la
cantidad de formas de llegar a este nodo
también va a ser tres más uno que es
cuatro y la cantidad de formas de llegar
a este nodo pues es otra vez simplemente
un 1
entonces estos cada uno de estos niveles
son los coeficientes que tenemos que
poner cuando desarrollamos un binomio
como estos que este es el coeficiente
cuando elevamos un binomio a la potencia
cero
estos son los coeficientes cuando
elevamos un binomio a la potencia 1
ok de hecho lo podemos ver si tenemos
este binomio elevado a la potencia 1 es
simplemente este binomio y el
coeficiente de la a es un 1 y el
coeficiente de la b es también un 1 son
estos unos de aquí que hay por aquí
estos son los coeficientes cuando
elevamos el binomio al cuadrado y los
coeficientes son 1 por a cuadrada más 2
por apruebe más 1 por b cuadrada y bueno
estos son los coeficientes cuando
elevamos el binomio a la tercera
potencia y
todos son los coeficientes cuando
elevamos el binomio a la cuarta potencia
entonces vamos a escribirlos por aquí
tenemos un 1 y luego un 4 luego un 6
luego otro 4 y luego un 1 y como vimos
en el vídeo pasado las potencias de a y
las potencias debe seguían como que
cierto patrón no la empezaba con la
potencia a la cual estábamos elevando el
binomio o sea a la 4 y después iba
disminuyendo su potencia entonces por
aquí nos toca a la 3 luego al cuadrado a
la 1 y bueno tenemos que poner a
alastair aunque sabemos que esto es
simplemente un 1 y las veces lo que
hacían era empezar como un 1 o sea ve a
la 0 y después y subiendo la potencia a
la cual estaban elevadas entonces aquí
nos queda
véala
ve al cuadrado ve a la 3 y la 4 y
después nada más tenemos que sumar todos
estos términos
ok esta es la expansión del binomio
además de a la 4 y podemos ver que nos
quedó exactamente igual que en el vídeo
pasado cierto o sea este término de aquí
es equivalente a este término de acá o
sea esta ve a la 0 es simplemente un 1 y
este otro término de aquí también es
equivalente a este término de acá y lo
mismo pasa con el resto de estos
términos aunque entonces con este
triángulo de pascal encontramos otra
forma de encontrar el desarrollo de un
binomio a la potencia 4 ahora una
pregunta muy interesante es por qué
funciona todo esto del triángulo de
pascal o sea porque nos quedó el mismo
resultado y bueno te sugiero que le
pongas una pausa y piensas al respecto
así es que bueno para ver por qué
obtenemos el mismo resultado
desarrollando el binomio y usando los
coeficientes del triángulo de pascal
pues vamos a necesitar usar unas
potencias más chicas
por ejemplo el binomio al cuadrado
entonces vamos a ver a más b al cuadrado
y bueno
además b al cuadrado es simplemente
ah
a más
be be great además ve por además ve y
esta multiplicación de aquí pues lo que
tenemos que hacer es tomar este por éste
que es a cuadrada y bueno esa es la
única forma que hay de obtener a
cuadrada cierta o sea de todos los
términos que vamos a obtener este es el
único que tiene a cuadrada y lleva este
coeficiente pero bueno sigamos
multiplicando luego tenemos que
multiplicar esta a por esta vez y nos
queda a por b y después tenemos que
multiplicar esta vez por esta a y pues
nos queda otra vez a b cierto entonces
tenemos por ahí otro a por b y
finalmente multiplicamos esta vez por
esta vez y nos queda b cuadrada y esto
es algo muy muy muy interesante porque a
ver otra vez cuántas formas hay de
obtener un cuadrado pues hay simplemente
una forma
multiplicar está por esta y yo tenemos
al cuadrado así es que hay una sola
forma de obtener a cuadrada
por otro lado cuántas formas hay de
obtener be cuadrada pues también hay
solamente una no tenemos que multiplicar
esta vez de este paréntesis por esta vez
de este paréntesis y obtenemos be
cuadrada pero pues hay únicamente una
forma de obtener be cuadrada sin embargo
a la hora de preguntarnos cuántas formas
hay de obtener a por b pues hasta aquí
podemos ver que hay dos formas de
obtener a por b no podemos tomar esta a
y multiplicarlo por esta vez o podemos
tomar esta vez y multiplicarla por esta
a mccray hay dos formas de obtener a por
b y este polinomio es igual a una forma
de obtener a cuadrada o sea a cuadrada
nada pues tenemos dos formas dos formas
de obtener a por b entonces el
coeficiente va a hacer 2 porque estamos
sumando dos de estos términos porque hay
dos formas de obtener este término
entonces tenemos dos por a o por b más
pues una sola forma de obtener de
cuadrada entonces de cuadrada entonces
mira tienen exactamente los mismos
coeficientes tenemos aquí 121 y aquí
tenemos 1 2 1
y lo mismo pasa para todas las demás
potencias ya que hay si tomamos un
binomio y lo elevamos a la tercera
potencia sus coeficientes van a ser 1 3
3 1 aunque ellas y como lo hicimos en
este ejemplo por game porque hay una
sola forma de obtener a al cubo que es
tomar todas las de todos los paréntesis
y multiplicar las
también sucede que hay una sola forma de
obtener ve al cubo que es tomar de cada
paréntesis la b y multiplicar las y
bueno como vimos en el vídeo pasado hay
tres formas de obtener a cuadrada por b
y tres formas de obtener a por be
cuadrada aunque hay en particular para
obtener a cuadrada por ver lo que
tenemos que hacer es escoger de los tres
posibles paréntesis uno que sea el que
va a aportar la b y los otros dos van a
aportar as entonces tendremos a cuadrado
por b pero pues tenemos tres formas de
escoger qué paréntesis es el que nos va
a dar la b bueno espero que esto te haya
parecido interesante